[vent qui souffle]
Question: Qu'est ce qui sort tous les jours à 6H pour vous présenter une vidéo en parlant d'un truc est plutôt cool comme dans
un calendrier de l'Avent parce que c'est un calendrier de l'Avent en 24 jours ?
Oui cette chaîne YouTube et vous avez répondu à cette énigme c'est pourquoi aujourd'hui je veux vous parler d'énigmes à vous peuple des internet.
J'ai sélectionné deux boîtes, de coffrets, qui sont sortis chez Larousse les deux, je crois, oui c'est ça. Un qui s'appelle "Casse-tête inferno"
C'est 60 défis 100%
machiavéliques alors après arrêtez de dire que nous on fait du putaclic... Sur tous les jeux il y a des titres putaclic. Soirées énigmes
250 casse tête machiavéliques (également) pour animer vos soirées. Alors je suis pas certain qu'on anime une soirée avec ça...
Celui-ci la boîte un petit peu abîmée; si vous avez l'oeil vous voyez que ça fait parti d'une gamme que je connais bien.
Ce style de boîte avec 250 cartes à l'intérieur...
Mais on dirait bien que c'est la même chose que mon jeu ! Ouais c'est dans la même série que
le jeu "Menteur Menteur" que j'ai sorti que vous trouvez aussi dans la description
Donc c'est très classique, il y a des styles d'énigmes
et vous avez l’énigme sur la carte et vous avez un livret avec toutes les réponses des énigmes. Il est sympa,
pour celui qui aime ça il y a
pas d'énigme trop surprenante mais il est très sympa à quelqu'un qui aimerait en fait
commencer à se mettre aux énigmes c'est tout à fait le genre de coffrets que vous pouvez lui offrir.
Par contre lui, si c'est vous qui aimez les énigmes fortement
je l'ai trouvé vraiment cool,
l'impression d'être un vieux cancrelat avec sa boîte... Parce qu'il décompose des cartes en énigmes différentes avec expérience du diabolique
avec des tests de logique mais surtout ce que j'aimais dans cette boîte
c'est énormément d’énigmes qui prennent le principe de la tour de Hanoï.
Connaissez-vous la tour de Hanoï ? Non ?! Ecoutez je vais vous expliquer, madame Chabaud [imite Sarko] La tour de Hanoï,
c'est un principe de cercle qui sont fournis
Genre c'est exceptionnel ils ont fournis les cercles !
Oui... car ce n'est pas toujours tout est fourni. Des cercles de différentes tailles qu'on va empiler.La tour d'Hanoi la plus simple c'est celle ci
est l'idée par exemple c'est d'imaginer qu'il y a une position ici, une ici, et une ici.
et on doit reconstituer la pile ici
avec deux contraintes: la contrainte une de la tour de Hanoi c'est qu'on ne peut déplacer les pièces qu'une par une.
Et articuler en option... et la contrainte numéro deux de la tour de Hanoi c'est que une
pièce ne peut jamais être posée sur une pièce plus petite qu'elle, a toujours être dans un ordre décroissant
la plus grosse en bas et la plus petite au dessus
Donc si par exemple on voulait se déplacer là, on ferait quelque chose un petit peu comme ça, si on imagine qu'il y avait trois positions,
et on aurait déplacé toute la tour de Hanoi
en respectant les deux contraintes. Et bien là il y a plus de cercles, il y en a 6.
Et il y a beaucoup d'énigmes dessus, c'est la première fois que je découvre en fait
une boîte d'énigmes qui a poussé le concept de la tour de Hanoi autant.
Avec autant de choses différentes et moi qui aime bien ça et bien pour la première fois j'ai pu m'éclater avec.
Les tests diaboliques et les tests de logique à l'intérieur sont assez chouettes aussi.
Avec des choses très légères comme celui-ci qui a vraiment juste un test de mise en perspective
mentale et ça j'aime bien, vous savez pour faire travailler la visualisation et la logique mentale, là c'est un système de cercles et de poulies.
et on doit juste en connaissant
le sens de rotation de la première, déterminer le sens de rotation de la dernière. Dans une ancienne vidéo que vous voyez apparaître
juste là haut,
je vous avez parlé de tesla et de sa capacité à visualiser des choses et comment vous pouviez vous aussi visualiser en 3D dans votre esprit.
Et bien ça, ça participe en plus à l'entraînement donc c'est assez chouette.
Et ça fonctionne comme des flashs cards, les réponses sont toujours derrière. Voilà j'ai adoré cette boîte.
J'ai bien aimé celle-ci mais vraiment elle s'adresse plus à ceux qui veulent un grand stock d'énigmes
six mètres, ou avoir un petit jeu comme ça à faire à l'apéro avec les copains mais
ça c'est plus coo,l alors c'est fait pour jouer à plusieurs, mais, si
si vous êtes comme moi que vous aimez ça, pour soi tout seul c'est très bien, et les deux sont au prix de...
Celle-ci est à 9€ celle-ci à 10,95€.
Voilà j'espère que ça vous a plu.
Merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette vidéo que vous pouvez liker comme d'habitude, vous retrouverez les références dans description.
Non, ce n'est pas un placement produit. Ce qui serait par exemple un placement de produit, ce serait de vous rappeler que dans la description il y a
également mes places pour l'Olympia, vous pouvez trouver ça, vous pouvez choisir votre siège, c'est plutôt cool.
C'est le bon cadeau de Noel. Vous pouvez vous abonner à la chaîne si ce n'est pas encore fait. Et rendez vous demain à 6H.
Ciao !
[musique]